مشاهدينا منوراتنا في جده انت المقدم
وانجا اهلا وسهلا فيك طبعا انت ده اول مره
يمكن فجاه صح لا ثاني مره
الفتره الاخيره عليك كانت حلوه وعملت يعني
من فتره كان عندك المسلسل وعمل ضجه كبيره
وكده وكان اول مره يمكن كمان جماهيريا
يصير كده من بعد فتره طويله انه يصير فيه
تفاعل وترند على طول بسبب المسلسل كيف
كانت التجربه لا طبعا لطيفه جدا يعني
الواحد لما بيحس انه شغله متشاف
ومتقدر وهمم عليه كلام وناس
لا بيفرح يعني لانه بيحس انه على الاقل في
اهتمام
لا يعني كان لطيف اعتقال هذا بنعمل
المسلسلات اللي شويه تحسي انه يعني
التفاعل اللي يصير معه يصير من كل الوطن
العربي ويصير الاراء فعليا فيفتي مناصفه
منقسمه ما بين اني انا حابه بالمسلسل او
الفكره وان انا لا شويه ايوه هذا نوع من
الصراعات مع الجمهور كيف تشوفي لا بشوفوا
حاجه صحيه جدا لانه معناها الناس بتتفرج
وهمم وعندها اراء
وبتتكلم وفي همم جدل كده عارفه في حاله من
التفاعل يعني حاجه حلوه يعني بتبسطني انه
باحس انه الشغل
شويه لا لا انا مش بخاف الحمد لله يعني
طول ما الواحد يعني مقتنع باللي هو بيعمله
همم بيقعد بقى بعد ما يخلص كده ويرتاح
يعني يتفرج على الردود الافعال يعني
الفنانين كثير الموضوع
اللمسه خرج الموسم انت من هدول الفنانون
الاولاد بصي انا سعيده جدا ان في منافسه
خارج الموسم لان احنا كان كل حاجه بتتكرس
في شهر واحد وده كان بيبقى متعب على
الممثلين وعلى المشاهدين يعني ما بيلحقوش
الحاجات في حاجات كانت بتظلم يعني ما
بيلحقش الناس يشوفوها وكانوا بياجروها
لبعض رمضان فان الحاجات تتفرق على السنه
كلها وان المنصات تبقى بتعرض انواع مختلفه
من مسلسلات السبع حلقات ال 15 حلقه
والثلاثين وال 45 ده بيخلي فيه طرائق يعني
فاهمه همم ولكني انا برده باحبه موسم
رمضان يعني باحس يمكن عشان بداياتي كانت
همم نصف رمضان كل سنه كان لازم ابقى
باشتغل في رمضان واقعد اتفرج على ردود بس
كمان مبسوطه بالمساحه الكبيره في كل السنه
دي طبعا همم عندك حاجه في رمضان دي لسه
بتجري او كده يعني بتكره اي حاجه او لا
بدك همم
لا ما فيش حاجه السنه دي همم السنه اللي
فاتت انا كنت واخده قرار اني ارتاح في
رمضان كانت اول سنه ما اشتغلتش في رمضان
انا كنت خارجه من وفيه صعب مده طويله قوي
مرهقه كان قواعد الطاقه 45 وستات البيت
المعادي في نفس الوقت يمكن عملت ظهور بس
خاصه في مسلسل راجعين يا هوى مع همم ايوه
اخراج الاستاذ محمد سلامه طبعا همم السنه
دي للاسف ما جاليش حاجه حلوه فيعني كان
نفسي اعمل حاجات بس ما جاءش حاجه حلوه
فعلا في دار مشاهد ههه لا والله طبعا
السنه دي كنت احب لا اكون مشاركه بس بس ما
فيش نصيب يعني ما فيهاش حاجه حلوه يعني
وانا وانا حبه يا اما اشتغل حاجه حقيقي
انا مبسوطه بها وحباها يا اما لا يا اما
اقعد بقى دول المشاهد عشان ما يبقاش بس
شغل من اجل الشغل يعني عايزه لما تكون
متواجده على حاجه بصراحه
لا كثير كثير
يعني لو هنتكلم عن المخرجين
الاستاذه كامله ابو ذكر طبعا انا بحبها
جدا اا استاذ شاكر خضير همم استاذ همم لا
لا والله مش عايزه انسى اسامي يعني ناس
كثير طبعا يعني استاذ هاني خليفه اشتغلت
معه قبل كده بحبه قوي وباحب اشتغل معه
ثاني همم لا ناس كثير همم
[موسيقى]
في التلفزيون
اه طيب وحاجه خارجه يعني تقديم البرامج
مثلا لمسابقات اه حاجه ممكن نشوفك كده
يعني شيء غير متوقع تفكري او لا لسه لا
نفس يعني لو هعمل حاجه كده نفسي اعمل
برنامج سفر في سفر واكل همم والمزيكا
وحاجه
تقديم اكثر من موضوع السفر
وبحب الاكل وباحب المزيكا
[موسيقى]